what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like we
know the next Marvel movie that Tom
Holland is going to be appearing in a
lot of people have been wondering about
Tom Holland's contract with Marvel
Studios also not to mention the fact
that he has a contract with Sony as well
Sony does have the rights to Spider-Man
but of course they worked out a deal
with Disney and Marvel Studios for Tom
Holland Spider-Man to appear in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and also
Andrew Garfield's and Toby Maguire
Spider-Man as well since they were in no
way home which took place inside of the
MCU things are looking good for Tom
Holland's new project to return to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe however it
looks like the next project that Tom
Holland is going to be a part of is
Spider-Man across the spider-verse the
sequel to Spider-Man Into the
spider-verse Now this right away is just
insanely cool however it means a lot
more than we actually think it does
because this is the setup this is a
start for something really big coming
down the road something even bigger than
Spider-Man and no way home and also it's
been reported that PS4 Spider-Man is
going to be in across the spider verse
as well and this also has serious
implications about what the future of
the Sony spider-verse is going to be
like and if it's anything like what
they're hinting at and what we're
expecting it to be like it's gonna blow
everybody's Minds now there's gonna be a
ton of different Spider-Man variants and
Spider-Man across the spider-verse but
it's looking like this isn't going to be
the only time that we're going to see a
bunch of different Spider-Man variants
on the screen in fact it's looking like
we could experience a live action into
the spider-verse film that Sony is going
to slowly build up to starting with
Madame Webb well I guess technically
Spider-Man no way home started it by
bringing the three Spider-Man together
but that took place in the MCU and
although it will definitely affect the
Sony spider-verse Madam Webb is going to
be the film that truly kicks off the new
Sony spider-verse so let's first talk
about Tom Holland and his contract and
then we'll talk about how this affects
the overall Sony Spider-Man universe in
a really great great way so I think a
lot of people know but in case you don't
Marvel Studios president Kevin feige and
Sony executive producer Amy Pascal right
after Spider-Man no way home came out
announced to the public to the fans that
Spider-Man is going to remain in the MCU
and they have already in fact begun
working on Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland
recently we haven't heard anything
official about Tom Holland signing a new
contract but we do have that guarantee
from Marvel Studios and Sony but it
looks like Tom Holland is going to be a
little bit more involved with Spider-Man
than we thought because according to a
report from the cosmic circus Tom
Holland Spider-Man from the MCU is going
to be in across the spider-verse now
this is really cool but it also opens up
a lot of questions because the report
specifically says that it will indeed be
the MCU Spider-Man so it's not Tom
Holland to play in a variant but the
actual Spider-Man from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the same Spider-Man
that went through all of the events of
no way home Avengers Infinity War
Avengers end game Captain America Civil
War and of course the homecoming Trilogy
so what does this mean for the future of
not only the spider-verse but the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as well because if we
truly get Tom Holland's MCU Spider-Man
in across the spider-verse that means
whatever events take place and happen
will affect him in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so that begs the question are
these universes kind of starting to
bleed into each other now they already
kind of had before in the past we have
Michael Keaton's vulture who went from
the MCU to the Sony Universe not to
mention they teased us with Tom Hardy's
Venom but that was very much a tease and
is looking like that actually won't
happen as they took him back and put him
back in the Sony universe but the point
being is the universe is kind of already
bleed into each other a little bit but
now we have another spider vs Multiverse
movie and the MCU Spider-Man is going to
be in it we also have Avenger Secret
Wars coming up where a bunch of
different universes are going to collide
due to some universes going through
incursion and we know we're going to see
a bunch of different variants of a lot
of different characters so the question
is will Spider-Man across the
spider-verse actually affect some slight
events in the MCU since our MCU
Spider-Man Tom Holland is going to be in
that film he'll get taken from the MCU
brought into the Sony Universe which is
the spider-verse right now and
theoretically and logically be put back
into the MCU so he's going to go through
a big event one that his character
probably can't ignore so yes the events
will probably bleed into the MCO even if
just a little bit and even if only
specifically for Tom Holland Spider-Man
but the cool thing about this is that it
really opens up something much bigger
thecosmiccircus.com also reports that
PS4 Spider-Man is going to be in across
the spider-verse but this isn't actually
the first time that PS4 Spider-Man has
left his Universe to appear in another
Marvel Spider-Man universe in the
massive comic event spider get in where
a ton of different Spider-Man variants
all go to one Universe PS4 Spider-Man
was taken from the video game and
brought into the Marvel Comics World and
yes it was the exact same PS4 Spider-Man
so it's going to be the same for across
the spiderverse but even more
importantly this tells us that Sony is
really not afraid to mix universes
regarding Spider-Man that is and recent
reports state that Sony is actually
working up to a spider get in movie now
I can't express how cool this would
actually be to see on screen and if
you've been following the channel for a
little bit you know that this idea is
massive and insanely cool it's
Spider-Man no way home on steroids it's
literally Spider-Man no way home times
10. and the story in the comics there
were over 15 different Spider-Man
variants in one universe together at the
same time so if you loved into the
spider-verse but wanted a live action
version of it well it's looking like
Sony is developing that right now and
they're actually building their entire
spider-verse to build up to this movie
now as far as Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is concerned there are some
other characters that have been reported
to be in the film which means they could
also cross into the live action spider
get in movie that hopefully Sony is
indeed making these new variants include
Jessica Drew's Spider-Woman supaida man
Scarlet Spider Punk cyborg Spider Woman
and Spider-Man India and of course we
can expect the entire gang from
Spider-Man into the spider-verse to
appear again of course the main
character Miles Morales spider Gwen
Peter Parker of course spider Noir and
all of the rest of the game and at one
point in time there was even a rumor
nothing confirmed but a rumor that Toby
Maguire and Andrew Garfield's Spider-Man
could appear in the film as well now
based off of everything that we've heard
from insiders after Spider-Man no way
home it does seem like Andrew Garfield
and Tobey Maguire aren't done with their
Spider-Man roles yet but in fact would
love to return to continue to play that
character in the Sony universe and it's
looking like there's going to be plenty
of opportunities for that to happen
right now there are some big reports
stating that Madam Webb is going to
explore other universes within the
spiderverse and there's a rumor going
around that Topher Grace's venom for
from Spider-Man 3 is going to appear in
Madame web as well as Dane de Hans Harry
Osborne from The Amazing Spider-Man both
of these characters exist in the
universes that Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield come from so if they are
revisiting their universes there's a big
chance that we're going to see Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield pop up again
at some point in time in the Sony
spider-verse but it is really cool that
Tom Holland is going to appear in across
the spider-verse it'll be cool to see
him slash hear him but it's also a
really good sign that Sony and Marvel
Studios Disney are indeed really working
well together right now which means Tom
Holland Spider-Man and the MCU has a
pretty bright future in fact the next
video that I'll be posting later on is
about Spider-Man 4 and the future of
Spider-Man and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so stay tuned for that be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out and in the
meantime let me know what you think
about Tom Holland Spider-Man appearing
in across the spider-verse along with
the PS4 Spider-Man which is a really
cool thing let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof